[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the historic
ebenezer baptist church
we are america's freedom church my name
is dr patrice c
turner and i serve as the director of
worship and the arts
here today we thank god for the life
of representative john robert lewis
and so at 11 am
we we shall join with churches
and institutions all over the land
and ring the bell for his life
80 times to represent his 80 years
here on earth let us remain silent and
remember
his contributions and legacy to our
people
at this time
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
amen we thank god for that moment
and now pastor warnock
and the family will enter the sanctuary
shall we
i am the resurrection and the light
said the lord
he that believeth in me though he was
dead
yet shall he live again
and whosoever lives and believes in me
shall never die
for i know that my redeemer lives
and that he shall stand with me and the
latter day of on the earth
though after my skin worms destroy this
body
yet in my flesh will i see god
whom i shall see for myself
and mine shall behold
and not another
behold i show you a mystery
we shall not all sleep
but we shall be changed
a moment in the twinkling of an eye
at the last trumpet
for the dead must be raised
incorruptable
and we shall all
be changed
this mortal must put on immortality
this corruptable must put on in
corruption and when
this corruptible shall have put on
incorruption
with this mortal shall have put on
immortality
then will be brought to pass the same
that is written
death is swallowed up in victory
oh death where is your sting
oh grand where is your victory
thanks be under god
who gives us the victory
thanks be unto god
who gave john robert lewis
the victory through jesus christ
our lord and liberator
let all the children of god say amen
you're in a baptist church say it louder
amen
god bless you my sisters and brothers
you who sit in the sanctuary
and those who join us on our church live
stream
or by television god bless you and
welcome to ebenezer baptist church
spiritual home of martin luther king jr
spiritual home of john robert lewis
america's freedom church
we have come to say farewell to our
friend
in these difficult days
that have even made grieving
more challenging at a time when we would
find
comfort in embracing one another
love compels us to socially distance
from one another but make no mistake
we are together in principle
even if not in proximity
we may not all be in the same room
but we are on the same page
and we are in touch with the same spirit
we love
john robert lewis
[Applause]
john lewis
[Applause]
boys
let me just offer this
we praise god for john lewis
and as we gather in this house of god
we're reminded that as a t
as a teenager he actually wrestled with
a call to ministry
a farm boy he used to preach to the
chickens
i guess you have to start somewhere
and at age 16 he preached what we
baptist called his trial
sermon in a little country church
but as his life took shape instead of
preaching sermons
he became one he became
a living walking sermon about
truth-telling
and justice making in the earth he loved
america
until america learned how to love him
back
we celebrate
[Applause]
at a time that there is so much going on
in our world the news cycle is packed
that moves out of dizzying space
pace yet for the last several days
it is as if time stood still while a
nation
takes its time to remember him
and i rise simply to ask
in this call to celebration
what is it that has summoned us here
and caused us to slow down to linger for
a little while
with so much swirling around us
we're summoned here because in a moment
when there are some in high office
who are much better at division than
vision
who cannot lead us so they seek to
divide us
in a moment when there is so much
political cynicism
and narcissism that masquerades as
patriotism
here lies a true american patriot
who risked his life and lived for the
hope
and the promise of democracy
we celebrate john lewis
beating them better but never bitter and
always
unbowed on a bridge in selma he stared
down bigotry and brutality and tyranny
and won
how did he do it the great great
grandson of slaves he received a
spiritual power
born of suffering a moral audacity that
transcended human station
and called upon the human law to more
closely align itself with the law
of love howard thurman said by some
amazing but vastly creative spirituality
the slave undertook the redemption of a
religion that the master
had profaned in his midst john lewis's
ancestors met a man named jesus
in the brush harbors of alabama and
georgia and mississippi and john
lewis received that faith and took it
with him across that bridge
in selma and every other bridge we've
come to celebrate john lewis
[Applause]
so let us be clear when president lyndon
baines johnson
picked up his pen to sign the voting
rights bill into law
what he etched in ink had already been
sanctioned by blood
the blood of the martyrs the blood of
schwerner cheney and goodman two jews
and an african-american who were
murdered
in mississippi the blood of viola luiso
the blood of john lewis
we celebrate john lewis he was wounded
for america's transgressions bruised for
our iniquities
the chastisement of our peace was upon
him
by his stripes we are healed
so let's remember him today and let's
recommit
tomorrow to standing together and
fighting together
and voting together and standing up on
behalf of truth and righteousness
together we'll get through this together
let's say the soul of our democracy
together
let's first of the
let's lord the lord together
thank god for john
robert lewis let the nation
say amen and let the angels
rejoice
good morning i will be coming from the
23rd number of songs the lord is my
shepherd
i shall not want he maketh me to lie
down in green pastures
he leadeth me beside the still waters he
restored my soul
he leadeth me in the path of
righteousness for his name's sake
yea though i walk with the valley of the
shadows of death
i will fear no evil for thou art with me
thy rod and thy death they comfort me
thou prepares the table before me in the
presence of my enemies
thou anointest my head with oil my cup
runneth over
surely goodness and mercy shall follow
me all
of the days of my life and i will dwell
in the house of the lord
forever thank you
good morning and i'll be reading
the uh first chronicles 13 chapter
if i could speak all the languages of
earth and of angels
but didn't love others i would only be a
noisy
gong or a clinging symbol if i had the
gift of prophecy
and if i understood all of god's secret
plans and possessed
all knowledge and if i had such faith
that i could move
mountains but didn't love others i would
be nothing
if i gave everything i have to the poor
and even sacrificed my body
i could boast about it but if i didn't
love others
i would have gained nothing love is
patient
and kind love is not jealous or boastful
or proud or rude it does not demand its
own way
it is not irritable and it keeps no
record of being wrong
it does not rejoice about injustice but
rejoices whenever the truth
wins out love never gives up
never loses faith is always hopeful
and endures through every circumstance
prophecy and speaking in an unknown
language in
unknown languages and special knowledge
will become useless
but love will last forever now our
knowledge is partial and incomplete
and even the gift of prophecy reveals
only part of the whole picture
but when the time of perfection comes
these partial things will become useless
when i was a child i spoke and thought
and reasoned
as a child but when i grew up i put away
childish things
now we see things imperfectly like
puzzling reflections in a mirror
but then we will see everything with
perfect clarity
all that i know now is partial and
incomplete
but then i will know everything
completely just as god now knows me
completely
three things will last forever faith
hope
and love and the greatest of these is
love
thank you
good morning
while we know that death is the great
equalizer we all recognize
that each person's experience with it is
different
and so i want to extend
condolences to you john miles
the siblings of john lewis and the
entire lewis
family on behalf of the entire king
family including my aunt christine
my dad's only living sibling who would
have been here with us today
but for covet but rest assured she is
viewing us
on television as we speak
let us pray
great and mighty god
who's creator of us all and sustainer of
all things
we invoke you on this morning
we welcome you holy spirit into this
place
we humbly look to you in this hour for
wisdom and strength
and comfort as we celebrate the
homegoing of your son
and servant congressman john robert
lewis please dear father comfort this
family
and grant them a peace of god that
passes all
understanding surround them
with your love in the words of your
servant martin luther king
jr who reminded us that death is not a
period that ends this great
sentence of life but a comma which
punctuates it to a lofty and higher
significance
help us oh god to grasp that truth and
see the magnitude
of this moment not merely
as the death of a great soul but as a
divine
message that says to each and every one
of us in this earth
be still and know that i am god
hear me and heed my message in this hour
that love even for an enemy is the only
way
to transform this world into a true
brother and sisterhood
we thank you god for the life and legacy
of congressman john lewis who showed us
this more excellent way of life
we thank you for honoring us with his
presence and allowing our lives to
intersect with his life be with his
family
be with those who struggle with him in
that movie
and know that he continues to live on
in and through each and every one of
them and each and every one of us
we praise your god for this non-violent
warrior
who fought for true peace which daddy
taught us is not merely the absence of
tension but the presence of justice
as we honor the life of congressman john
lewis
who shed blood on that edmund pres
pettis bridge
that we might have the right to vote
grant that we
never again take that right for granted
and that we
exercise it no matter what and that we
never again tamper with that right
overtaking this hour our congress that
they might restore
voting rights protections in our nation
as we honor the life of this non-violent
warrior
who embodied the very spirit of christ
and showed us that we have the spiritual
power
to resist injustice and evil and hatred
and vitriol with the force of love and
truth we are
eternally grateful oh god that he lived
among us for four score years
and demonstrated on that bridge that
physical force
is no match for soul force grant us the
capacity
to follow his example to fight injustice
without bitterness and hostility but
with a righteous indignation
oh god as elisha asked for a double
portion
of elijah's anointing as as he
transitioned
let a double portion of what john
lewis's life
was about fall on us in this hour so
that we can continue to get in good
trouble
anoint us with a double portion in this
generation
to get into good trouble until there is
radical reform
in policing in our nation anointing is a
double portion
to get into good trouble until voter
suppression is no longer
a part of our body poverty anoint us
with a double portion to get into good
trouble
until there is an equitable distribution
of wealth in this nation
until everyone has a livable wage and
affordable housing and good health care
anoint us oh god with a double portion
to get into good trouble until all
labor is treated with dignity grant us
our father
a double portion to get into good
trouble until the school-to-prison
pipeline
is non-existent and every child gets an
equitable education
grant us dear god a double portion to
get into good trouble
until white supremacy around the world
is uprooted and dismantled
in all of our policies and everyday
practices
and behaviors no longer reflect white
supremacy
grant us a double portion god
to get into good trouble until this
nation truly becomes a compassionate
nation
because as daddy reminded us ultimately
a
great nation is a compassionate nation
grant us love god a double portion
of anointing to get into good trouble
until black bodies are no longer a
threat
in this world and black lives
have equitable representation power
and influence in every arena
grant us finally father god had
a double portion to get into good
trouble
until love becomes the way we live
the way we lead the way we legislate
and until justice rolls down like waters
and righteousness like a mighty stream
thank you oh god for this great man
who lived among us who now joins the
great cloud
of freedom fighters and lord we thank
you
for his life and his legacy
and we will continue to get into good
trouble
as long as you grant us the breath to do
so
it is in the matchless in the majestic
and the mighty name of jesus the christ
that i do pray and all the people of god
said together
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
you may build
great cathedrals
large or small
[Music]
[Music]
you may conquer
all the failures
of your past
but only
what do you do for christmas
you may seek
earthly power
wealth and fame
[Music]
and the world
might be impressed
by your great name
soon the glories
of this life
will all soon be paid
[Music]
what do you do for christ
will last
remember
[Music]
christ will last
now
[Music]
[Music]
when
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
counted
[Applause]
[Music]
what you do
well it's gonna last
what you do for christmas
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
know
this is john lewis's favorite poem
invictus
out of the night that covers me black as
a pit from poe to pole
i think whatever god may be for my
unconquerable soul
in the fellow clutches of circumstance i
have not went
nor cried aloud under the bludgeonings
of chance
my my head is bloody but unbowed
beyond this place of wrath and tears
looms but the horror of the shade
and yet menace of the years
finds and shall find me unafraid
it it matters now how straight the game
how charged with punishment the scroll
i'm the master of my fate
i'm the captain of my soul
john lewis was my hero my friend let's
honor him by getting in good trouble
only the unconquerable spirit
and the magnanimous soul of john lewis
could summon all of us together
in this place at this time
only john lewis could compel
three living american presidents
to come to this house to celebrate his
life
we are grateful that all of them are
here
the honorable george w bush
who was president the last time we
authorized the voting rights
the honorable william jefferson clinton
[Applause]
and in just a little while we'll hear
from the honorable barack
[Applause]
obama
but the program will proceed as printed
president bush president clinton
speaker of the house nancy pelosi
and
and another living saint among us
teacher and activist the reverend james
lawson
good morning distinguished guest
john miles louis family and friends
lauren i thank you for inviting us to be
here today
john's story began on a tiny farm in
troy alabama a place so small
he said you could barely find it on the
map
dr weinach talked about the chickens
i did a little research every morning he
would
rise before the sun to tend to the flock
of chickens
he loved those chickens
already called to be a minister who took
care of others john fed them
and tended to their every need
even their spiritual ones
for john baptized them he married them
and he preached to them
when his parents claimed one for family
supper
john refused to eat one of his flock
going hungry was his first act of
non-violent protest
he also noted in later years that his
first congregation of chickens
listened to him more closely than some
of his colleagues in congress
john also thought that chickens were
just a little more productive
at least they produced eggs he said
from troy to the city ends of nashville
from the freedom rides to the march on
washington from
freedom summer to selma john lewis
always looked outward not inward
he always thought of others
he always believed in preaching the
gospel in word and indeed
insisting that hate and fear had to be
answered
with love and hope john lewis believed
in the lord
he believed in humanity and he believed
in america
he's been called an american saint
a believer willing to give up everything
even life itself to bear witness to the
truth that drove him all his life
that we could build a world of peace and
justice harmony and dignity
and love and the first crucial step on
that journey
was the recognition that all people
are born in the image of god and carry
a spark of the divine within them
laura and i were privileged to see that
spark in john up close
we work with him to bring the national
museum of african american history and
culture to the washington mall
he was instrumental in the emmett till
unsolved civil rights crimes act
which i signed to seek resolution in
cases where justice
had been too long denied
and we will never forget joining him
in selma alabama for the 50th
anniversary of his march across the
edmund pettus bridge
where we got to watch president barack
obama
thank john as one of his heroes
there's a story in the old scriptures
that meant a lot to john
in the hebrew bible the lord is looking
for a prophet
whom shall i send god wonders and who
will go for us
isaiah answers here am i
send me john lewis heard that call
a long time ago in segregated alabama
and he took up the work of the lord
through all his days
his lesson for us is that we must all
keep ourselves open
to the hearing here uh open to hearing
the call of love
the call of service and the call to
sacrifice for others
listen john and i had our disagreements
of course
but in the america john lewis fought for
and the america i believe
in differences of opinion are inevitable
elements and evidence
of democracy in action
we the people including congressmen and
presidents
can have differing views on how to
perfect our union
while sharing the conviction that our
nation however flawed
is at heart a good and noble one
we live in a better and nobler country
today because of john lewis
and his abiding faith in the power of
god
in the power of democracy and in the
power of love
to lift us all to a higher ground
the story that began in troy isn't
ending here today
nor is the work john lewis lives forever
in his father's house
and he will live forever in the hearts
of americans
who act justly love mercy
and walk humbly with their god
may the flights of angels
see john lewis to his rest and may god
bless the country he loved
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much
first i thank john miles and the lewis
family
and john's incomparable staff for a
chance to say
a few words about a man i love
for a long time
i am grateful pastor warnock to say it
in ebenezer
a holy place sanctified
by both the faith and the works
of those who have worshiped here
i thank my friend reverend bernice king
who stood by my side and gave a
fascinating sermon in one of the most
challenging periods of my life
i thank president mrs bush president
obama
speaker pelosi thank you and
representative hoyer and
representative clyburn
for with the stroke of a hand
ending an intra family
fight within our party
proving that peace is needed by
everyone
madam mayor thank you you have faced
more than a fair share of challenges
in these last few months and you have
faced them with
candor and dignity and honor
and i thank you for your leadership
i must say
for a fellow that got to start
speaking to chickens
john's gotten a pretty finely organized
and orchestrated and deeply deserved
send-off this last week
we his homegoing has been something to
behold
i think it's important that
all of us who loved him remember that he
was after all
a human being a man
like all other humans born with
strengths
that he made the most of when many don't
born with weaknesses that he worked hard
to beat down when many can't
but still a person it made him more
interesting
and it made him in my mind even greater
20 years ago we celebrated the 35th
anniversary of
the selma march and we walked together
along with
coretta and
many others from the movement
who are no longer with us
we're grateful for andy young and
reverend jackson and diane nash and many
others who survived
but on that day
i got him to replay for me
a story he told me when we first met
back in the 1970s
and i said
you know i was just an aspiring whatever
southern politician and
hadn't been elected governor and he was
already a legend
so i said john what's the closest you
ever actually came to getting killed
doing this
and he said well once we were in a
demonstration and
i got knocked down on the ground and
people were getting beat up pretty bad
and all of a sudden i looked up and
there was a man holding a long heavy
piece of pipe
and he lifted it and was clearly going
to bring it right down
into my skull and at the very last
second i turned my neck away and the
crowd pushed him a little bit and
a couple seconds later i couldn't
believe i was still alive
i think it's important to remember that
first because he was a quick thinker
and secondly because
he was here on a mission that was bigger
than
personal ambition things like that
sometimes just happen but usually they
don't
i think three things happened to john
lewis long before we met
and became friends that made him who he
was
first the famous story of john at four
with his cousins and siblings
holding his aunt's hand more than a
dozen of them
running around a little old wooden house
as the wind threatened to blow the house
off its moorings going to the place
where the house was rising and
all those tiny bodies trying to weigh it
down
i think you learned something about the
power of working
together
something that was more powerful than
any instruction
second nearly 20 years later when he was
23 the youngest
speaker and the last speaker
at the march on washington
when he gave a great speech urging
people to take
to the streets across the south
to seize the chance to finally end
racism
and he listened to people that he knew
had the same goals say well we have to
be careful how we say this because we're
trying to get
converts not more adversaries
just three years later he lost the
leadership of
snick to stokely carmichael
because he said you know i'd really i
mean it was a pretty good job for a guy
that young and
come from troy alabama it must have been
painful
to lose but
he showed as a young man there are some
things
that you cannot do to hang on
to a position because if you do them you
won't be who you
are anymore and i
say there were two or three years there
where
the movement went a little bit
too far towards stokely but
in the end john lewis prevailed
we are here today because he had the
kind of character
he showed when he lost an election
then there was bloody sunday
he figured he might get arrested
and this is really important not to
for all the rapsodic things we all
believe about john lewis
he had a really good mind and he was
always trying to figure out how can i
make the most of every single moment
so he's getting ready to march
from selma to montgomery he wants to get
across the bridge
what do we remember he had he made a
cut quite a strange figure he had a
trench coat and a backpack
now young people probably think that's
no big deal but but
there weren't that many backpacks back
then and you never saw
anybody in a trench coat looking halfway
dressed up with a backpack
but john put an apple an orange a
toothbrush toothpaste
in the backpack to take care of his body
because he figured he would get arrested
in two books one a book by richard
hofstadter on
america's political tradition to feed
his mind
and one the autobiography of thomas
merton
a roman catholic trappist
monk who was the son
of itinerant artists making an
astonishing personal transformation
once a young guy who's about to get his
brain speed out
and planning on going to prison doing
taking that i think he figured
that if thomas merton could find his way
and keep his faith
and believe in the future he john lewis
could too
and
so we honor our friend
for his faith and for living its faith
which the scripture says is the
substance of things hoped for
the evidence of things unseen
john lewis was a walking rebuke to
people
who thought well we ain't there yet
we've been working a long time
isn't it time to bag it
he kept moving he hoped for
and imagined and lived and worked and
moved for
his beloved community
he took a savage beating on more than
one day
and he lost that backpack on bloody
sunday
nobody really knows what happened to it
maybe someday someone will be stricken
with conscience and give some of it back
but what it represented never
disappeared from john lewis's
spirit
we honor that memory today because as a
child he learned to walk with the wind
to march with others to save a tiny
house
because as a young man he challenged
others to join him
with love and dignity to hold america's
house down
and open the doors of america to all its
people
we honor him because in selma on the
third attempt
john and his comrades showed that
sometimes you have to walk into the wind
along with with it
as he crossed the bridge and marched
into montgomery
but no matter what john always kept
walking to reach
the beloved community
he got into a lot of good trouble along
the way but let's not forget
he also developed an absolutely uncanny
ability
to heal troubled waters
when he could have been angry and
determined to cancel his adversaries
he tried to get converts instead
he thought the open hand was better than
the clinch
fists
he lived by the faith and promise of
saint paul let us not grow weary in
doing good
for in due season we will reap if we do
not lose heart
he never lost heart
he fought the good fight he kept the
faith
but we got our last letter today on
the page of the new york times
keep moving
it is so fitting on the day of his
service he leaves us our marching orders
keep moving 20 years ago when i came
here after the selma march to a big
dinner honoring john and lillian and
john miles
you had a big afro
and it was really pretty
and your daddy was giving you grief
about it and i said john let's don't get
old too soon i mean if i had hair like
that
i'd have it down to my shoulders
on that night i was almost out of time
and people were
to be present and people were asking me
well if you could do one more thing what
it would be or what do you wish you had
you had done that you didn't and all
that kind of stuff
and someone asked me that night
because i had many friends in atlanta
and i said if i could just do
one thing
if god came to me tonight and said okay
your time's up you got to go home
and i'm not a genie i'm not giving you
three wishes
one thing what would it be
i said i would
infect
every american
with whatever it was
that john lewis got as a four-year-old
kid
and took through a lifetime to keep
moving
and keep moving in the right direction
and keep bringing other people to move
and to do it without hatred in his heart
with a song to be able to sing and dance
as john's brother freddie said in troy
keep moving to the ballot box even if
it's a mailbox
and keep moving to the beloved community
john lewis was many things
but he was a man
a friend in sunshine and storm
a friend who would walk the stoney roads
that he asked you to walk that would
brave the chastening rods he asked you
to be whipped by always keeping his eyes
on the prize always believing
none of us will be free until all of us
are equal
i just loved it
i always will
and i'm so grateful that he stayed true
to form
he's gone up yonder and left us with
marching orders
i suggest since he's close enough to god
to keep his eye on the sparrow
and us we salute
suit up and march on
[Applause]
good day i'm not sure morning afternoon
whatever it is it's an honor to be here
with each and every one of you
reverend warnock thank you for and
enabling us all to be here
in the ebenezer baptist church to honor
them
and celebrate the life of john lewis
with three presidents of the united
states
isn't that exciting
president clinton president bush and
soon
president obama here with us
on behalf of my colleagues as speaker of
the house
i'm pleased to bring greetings to each
and every one of you i'm sad
to bring condolences to the family to
john
miles to the entire lewis family
thank you for sharing john lewis with
us i'm pleased to be here with so many
members 50
we would have had more except
coronavirus prevented the
chair sherman long ways to bring more
but i hope they will all stand members
of the house of representatives
senators harris and booker who are with
us as well
senators harrison
among them uh mr hoyer
stenny hoyer mr climber and jim clyburn
and i served with john lewis
for over 30 years over over 30 years
and in our group we have senior members
and we have members of our freshman
class john convinced each one of us that
we were his best
friend in congress and we come with a
flag flown over the capitol
the night the john passed when this flag
flew there
it said goodbye that wave goodbye to
john
our friend our mentor our colleague
this beautiful man that we all had the
privilege
of serving with in the congress of the
united states
so again we all bring our condolences to
the family
and to michael collins and john's staff
who meant so very much
to him thank you for their service to
john lewis
there are many things we're grateful to
the family for and to the staff for
and we commend them for but let's
acknowledge the stamina they have had to
keep up with
john even as he passed on from
troy to selma to montgomery to
washington
and now to atlanta uh to be at rest
when john lewis served with us he wanted
us to see
the civil rights movement and the rest
through his eyes
he told us so many stories he taught us
so much
and he took us to selma
for two decades mr president he took us
to selma you
referenced 25 years some of us through
there many many times including
50th anniversary where president bush
was as well as
president obama and he wanted us to
see how important it was
how important it was to understand the
spirit of non-violence
i hesitate to speak about non-violence
in the presidents of the master himself
reverend lawson we're hearing we'll be
hearing from shortly
we were together just recently in selma
when he
and john spoke at church and he he
taught
the world really about non-violence but
i just want to say this
the word satyagraha is a
word that in sanskrit means two things
it means non-violence and it means
insistence on the truth
and that is what john lewis was
all about non-violently
insisting on the truth he insisted on
the truth of nashville and selma
in washington d.c at lincoln memorial
insisting on the truth
wherever he went and he insisted on the
truth
in the congress of the united states
every time he stood up to speak
we knew that he was going to take us to
a higher place of our understanding of
what our responsibilities were
and what our opportunities were and he
insisted
no matter how shall we say offended
someone might be
that he would insist on the truth
what he said he said in my life
i have done all i can to demonstrate
that the way of peace the way of love
and non-violence is the more excellent
way
now it is your turn he says in this
article the president referenced
to let freedom ring he always talked
about truth
marching on he always worked for a more
perfect union
over the fourth of july weekend i had
the privilege of visiting
with john and i brought him
this flag pin that i wear one just like
it
why i did so on that fourth of july
weekend was because it is engraved with
something that says
country one destiny
now wasn't that what john lewis was all
about
one country one destiny i mention
it because this was sewn
into embroidered into the lining
of abraham lincoln's coat that he had on
the night he left us i think he had the
coat on
all the time but also that night
and john lewis and abraham lincoln
had so much in common uh
john began we got to know him first and
foremost in front of the lincoln
memorial
when he made that beautiful beautiful
speech
john
lyon state under the rotunda
and the rotunda the capital under the
dome of the capitol
on a catapult a platform
that was made in 1865
to hold the casket of abraham lincoln
abraham lincoln john lewis
john lewis so they had lots of
connections and by the way just
incidentally
they were both wonderful and spiritual
and saintly but they were both very good
politicians think of john lewis that way
you who know him know that he always was
about
a more perfect union and he was
always about young people that's why
mr president that article you referenced
in the new york times today
his message that would be delivered
at this time as he left us was about
young people he said to them
together you can redeem the world
together
always perfect uni together one nation
one destiny
and he says in the article answer the
highest calling of your heart
and stand for stand up for what you
truly
believe in wasn't that just like john
we were very proud to have his voice in
the rotunda
speaking about all that he cared about
believed in in such a
beautiful way starting in troy
i started my remarks by talking about
the flag
that waved over the capitol to say
goodbye to john
as he began his passage
but what i want you to know in addition
to how revered
he is in the congress so revered
that you know he was a bit mischievous
you know he
he when he would say let's make some
good trouble
he always had sort of a twinkle in his
eye and a kind of a spark about it all
and my colleagues can tell you that when
he uh
cooked up having the sit-in
to get the republican leadership to put
the gun violence prevention bill on the
floor
when he did that and all the members
followed him the floor was covered
with people and thought for a moment
that perhaps
the police might because it was
disruptive
good trouble it was clear to them
that if they were to arrest john lewis
for doing that
they were going to have to rest the
entire
house democratic caucus
so when he spoke people listened
when he led people followed we loved him
very much
as his official family we mourn him
greatly he
shared so much with that his love for
his district his family
the sadness when lillian was sick
the joy he had in john miles
but as i said we waved goodbye to this
person
our leader our friend this shall we say
uh humorous he loved to dance
he loved to make us laugh sometimes
while he was dancing
he said my granddaughter bella said to
him did you ever sing in the
civil rights movement he said they asked
me to sing solo one time
so low so that nobody could hear me
but anyway getting back to that flag
waving goodbye to this
person we had just loved officially
personally in every way
politically too
the last night he was at the capitol
it wasn't raining thousands of people
were showing up to pay their respects
a little bit after eight o'clock there
was a double
rainbow a double
rainbow but it hadn't rained it was a
double rainbow
over the casket and for us
it was we waved goodbye when he started
to leave us
he was telling us he was telling us
i'm home in heaven i'm home in heaven
with lillian
we always knew he worked on the side of
the angels
and now he is with him may he rest in
peace
thank you
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pastor sisters and brothers
members of this lewis family
that uh so
wonderfully nurtured
john in love hope and courage and faith
and the rest of it
and sisters and brothers
cecil off milosa
a polish catholic poet
sets the tone at least in part for me as
john lewis
has journeyed from the eternity
of this extraordinary mysterious human
race
into the eternity that none of us know
very much
about when he wrote this poem
called meaning
when i die i will see the lining
of the world the other side
beyond bird mountain sunset
the true meaning ready to be decoded
what never added up will now
add up what was incomprehensible
will comprehended
and if there is no
lining to the world
if a thrush on a branch
is not a sign but just
a thrush on a branch
if night and day make no sense
following each other and on this earth
there is nothing
but the earth
even if that is so
there will remain a word
awakened by the lips that perish
a tireless messenger who runs and runs
through interstellar places
through revolving galaxies and calls out
and protests and screams
and i submit that john and that other
eternity
will be heard by us again and again
running through the galaxies
still proclaiming
that we the people of the usa can one
day
live up to the full meaning of we hold
these truths
live up to the full meaning we the
people of the usa
in order to perfect a more perfect union
john lewis practiced not the politics
that we call bipartisan john lewis
practiced the politics that we the
people of the us need
more desperately than ever or before
the politics of the declaration of
independence
politics
of the preamble to the constitution of
the united states
i've read many of the so-called civil
rights books of the last
50 or 60 years about the period between
1953
and 1973.
most of the books are wrong about john
lewis
most of the books are wrong about how
john got engaged
in the national campaign of 1959-60
this is the 60th year of the sit-in
campaign
which swept into every state of the
union
largely manned by students because we
recruited students
but put up on the map that the
nonviolent struggle begun
in montgomery alabama was not an
accident
but as martin king jr called it
christian love
has power that we have never tapped
and if we use it we can transform not
only our own lives but we will transform
the earth
in which we live
i counted providential that as i moved
to nashville tennessee dropping out of
graduate school
in nashville kane people like kelly
miller smith and andrew white
and janetta hayes
and helen roberts and dolores wilkerson
and john lewis diane nash
ct vivian marion berry
jim beville bernard lafayette
paulina knight angela butler
how all of us gathered in 1958
and 59 and 16 61 and 62
in the same city at the same time i
count as being providential
we did not plan it we were all led there
and when kelly miller smith and the
national christian leadership council
met
in the fall of 1958
and we determined that if there's to be
a second major campaign
that will demonstrate the efficacy of
satyagraha
of soul force of love truth
that we would have to do it in nashville
and so i planned as the strategist and
organizer a four-point
gandhian strategic program
to create the campaign
we decided with great fear and
anticipation
we would desegregate downtown nashville
no group of black people or other people
anywhere in the united states in the
20th century against the rapaciousness
of a segregated system ever thought
about
desegregating downtown
tearing down the signs renovating the
waiting rooms
taking the immoral signs off of
off of drinking fountains
but it was black women who made that
decision for us
in nashville i was scared to death
when we made that decision i knew
nothing
about how we were going to do this
i had never done it before
but we planned the strategy
john lewis did not stumble in on
that campaign kelly miller smith
his teacher at abc invited
john to join the workshops in the fall
of 1959
as we prepared ourselves to face
violence
and to do direct action and to put on
the map
the issue that the racism and the
segregation of the
nation had to end
so in the 60th anniversary of that
sit-in campaign
which became the second major campaign
of the non-violent movement of america
those are not my words john lewis called
what we did between 1970
53 and 1973 the non-violent movement of
america
not the crm
i think we need to get the story
straight because words
are powerful history must be written in
such a fashion
that it lifts up truly the spirit
of the john lewises of the world
[Applause]
and that's why i've chosen just to say a
few words about it
kelly miller smith invited john
lewis i met a fist student who told me
about a
student from chicago who wanted to do
something about those vicious signs
i said invite invite diane
nash to the workshop in september
because we're going to do something
about those signs
i i pushed this heart
now john lewis had no choice in the
matter
you should understand that
because all the stories we've heard this
morning of john
becoming a preacher preaching
to the chickens and other sorts of
things becoming ordained as a baptist
minister
something else was happening to john
in those early years
john saw the malignancy
of racism in troy
alabama they're formed
in him a sensibility
that he had to do something about it
he did not know what that was
but he was convinced that he was called
indeed to do
whatever he could do get in good trouble
but stop the horror
that so many folk lived through and in
in this country in that part of the 20th
century
john was not alone martin king had the
same experience as a boy
i had the same experience from age four
in the streets of maslin ohio
matthew mccullough a pastor whose name
you don't know
in south carolina had the same
experience c.t
vivian had the same experience
i maintain that many of us had no choice
to do what we tried to do
primarily because at an early age
we recognized the wrong under which
we were forced to live and we swore
to god that by god's grace
we would do whatever god called us to do
in order to put on the table
of the nation's agenda this
must end black lives matter
and so between 1953 and 1973
we had major campaigns year after year
thousands of demonstrations across the
nation that supported it
we had folk in the congress folk in the
white house
folks kept scattered across the united
states who were
beginning to formulate what the
solutions are for change
the media makes a mistake when john is
seen only in relationship to the voting
rights bill of 65.
how ever important that is you must not
remember that
in the 60s lyndon johnson and the
congress of the united states
passed the most advanced legislation
on behalf of we the people of the united
states that was ever passed
head start
billions of dollars for housing we would
not be in the struggle we are today in
housing if
president reagan hadn't cut that
billions of dollars for housing
where local churches and local
non-profits could build
affordable housing in their own
communities
being sustained and financed by loans
from the federal government
we passed medicare
we passed anti-poverty programs
civil rights bill 64 65
voting rights bills
a whole array john lewis
must be represented must be understood
as one of the leaders
of the greatest advance of congress in
the white house
on behalf of we the people of the usa
we do not need
bipartisan products if we're going to
celebrate the life of john lewis
we need the constitution to come alive
we hold these truths to be self-evident
we need the congress and the presidents
to work unfalteringly
on behalf of every boy and every girl so
that every baby born and these shores
will have
access to the tree of life
that's the only way to honor
john robert
lewis no other way
let all of us in this service today
let all the people of the usa determine
that we will not be quiet as long as any
child
dies in the first year of life in the
united states
we will not be quiet as long as the
largest poverty group in our nation
are women and children
we will not be quiet as long as our
nation continues to be the most
violent culture in the history of
humankind
we will not be quiet as long as our
economy is shaped
not by freedom but by plantation
capitalism
that continues to cause domination and
control
rather than access and liberty and
equality for
all
[Applause]
the forces of spiritual wickedness a
strong
in our land because of our history we
have not created them
john lewis did not create them we
inherited them
but it's our task to see those spiritual
forces
i've named them racism sexism
violence plantation capitalism
those poisoned still dominate far too
many of us
in many different ways john's life
was a singular journey
from birth through the campaigns in the
south
through congress to get us to see
that these forces of wickedness
must be resisted
do not let our own hearts drink any of
that poison
instead drink the truth
of the life force
if we would honor and celebrate john
lewis's life let us then
recommit our souls our minds our hearts
our bodies our strength
to the continuing journey to dismantle
the wrong in our midst
and to allow a space
for the new earth and new heaven to
emerge
i close with this poem from langston
huge
which is a kind of a sign and symbol of
what john lewis
represents and what we too
can represent in our continuing journey
hughes i dream a world
where no human
no other human will scorn
where love will bless the earth
and peace its past adorn
i dream a dream where all
will know sweet freedom's way
where greed no longer saps the soul
nor avarice blights
our day a world i dream
black and white and yellow and blue and
green and red
and brown whatever your race
may be will share the bounties
of the earth and every
woman and man and boy and girl
is free where wretchedness hangs
its head and joy like a pearl
attends the need of all humankind
the chats of such a world
i dream celebrate
life dream
and labor for an atlanta
and los angeles in the united states
and a world
that is to celebrate the spirit in the
heart
and the mind and soul of john lewis
and to walk with him through the
galaxies
seeking equality liberty justice and the
beloved community
for all
thank you
you
three living presidents with us today
we have heard from yet another to the
friends and family of congressman john
lewis
rosalind joins me in sending our
condolences
to all gathered today to mourn the loss
of one of our nation's great leaders
throughout his remarkable life john has
been a blessing to countless people
and we are proud to be among those whose
lives he has touched
while his achievements are enjoyed by
all americans
we georgians know him as our neighbor
friend
and representative his enormous
contributions will continue to be an
inspiration
for generations to come please know that
you are in our hearts
and prayers during this difficult time
we hope your warm memories and the love
and prayers of your family and friends
will be of comfort to you
in the days ahead sincerely
jimmy carter
[Music]
if i can help
[Music]
somebody
as i pass up
long
if i can chase
[Music]
if i can show
[Music]
somebody
that he's
wrong
then my living
it shall not
be
[Music]
stand up
yes my
living
shall not
be in vain
if i could
as i pass
along
[Music]
then my living
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
childhood
oh if i can do
my duty
[Applause]
if i can bring
[Music]
up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
message
[Music]
not be
in vain
[Music]
then my
[Music]
living room
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shall not be
if i could help somebody
then my living
it shall not
[Music]
yes
[Music]
shall not
be
in vain
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to first call attention
to the excellent job the media has done
to inform us of john lewis hasn't the
media been
tremendous in keeping us informed
i've never seen such coverage
but john deserved it but i want to talk
a moment
at my presentation on john
before he became famous
i met john i came to atlanta
london miles and i came to atlanta on
the same day
she came to work at the university
of atlanta university and i came to work
for martin luther king jr
in the southern christian leadership
conference and that's when i met john
saw him all the time we were all
involved in the same
quest for equity and justice
in this america and i got a chance to
see him
all the time and i admired his fervor
and all of his tenacity and
lillian was single and so i decided
that lillian needed a good man
not just the bums who were approaching
her
she was highly intellectual
well-traveled
well-educated and i wanted her to have
someone
who really would appreciate
her skills and her talent so i looked
around
and decided that i liked john
but lillian didn't like john
particularly
and so she thought he was kind of slow
and i said but lily he's busy he's
fighting the
evils of the world and she said
yes but well i decided
girl listen this boy is going places
so let's see what he can do to get this
thing moving so we decided
what i did uh as her friend and that's
what you do for friends you have to help
them out
so john had to go to the hospital
for uh examination and
i said oh lillian this would be a good
moment
for us to be florence nightingale so we
went to the grocery store and bought a
little bunch of flowers
and took it to the hospital i said he'll
be impressed
because he was a little slow too and
um i said we'll go to the hospital
and that would just impress him that he
will notice you more
because you bring him flowers while he's
in the hospital
well we got in the hospital and there
was a young woman already there
and she was struggling out his pillow
and adjusting his comfort
and then lillian said oh shoot well i
said but i've already asked john
john do you have a young woman who you
are especially interested in
and he said well not really
and i said that's not the answer i'm
looking for
i want a more defensive answer because i
got some things in mind
well you know john was just slow about
well not really well i decided on
uh new year's eve um
lolan was single as i said and didn't
have any plans so i said well i'll have
a
dinner party invite the two of them
and maybe they'll give us a chance i was
known as the one who gave vic
party so lillian thought i was gonna
have a big party
john thought i was having a big party
when they got to my house
that was on a room for three of us
the two of them and me
and so now we're discussing the wilds of
the world
and i'm hoping now that they're gonna
get a little closer and closer
well because and when john didn't have a
date
on new year's eve i knew he didn't have
a commitment
everybody has a date on new year's eve
with somebody somewhere
so i figured well i'm ahead of the game
now it's new year's eve and here i've
got him
and then things start happening
and still slowly not fast enough for me
but i was patient
and finally little and said i do like
him
i said okay i'm ready now i set a date
got a dress ready and we're gonna have a
wedding
and so and i'm not really sure i asked
john not too long ago did we ever ask
you
would you take her i don't think i ever
got that much
opportunity to propose we just had a
wedding
[Applause]
and so now it looks like things were
going to be okay so we had a big wedding
i did all the planning because lily was
still slow
and i did all the planning and had the
big wedding all the family came so we
had a wedding
now things were doing okay
and she said you know but i don't like
the idea of that girl
looks like she had you know some designs
on
john i said honey don't run away from
competition we can handle competition
we'll get rid of that girl so fast she
won't know what happened to her
and we did and i got now
well i want you to know they were
very happy but
when she found out now lillian as i said
well traveled
well educated but she absolutely didn't
like
politics sorry people she didn't like
politics
but when john expressed an interest
lillian got in there and became his
strongest
supporter i mean she did everything
everything to make his successes
work for him and they did well then
john miles came along and he was the
cutest little boy
and then she said they gave me the honor
of being his godmother and i said oh
that's
nice and i've heard of god much but what
what does godmother do
what am i supposed to do and she said
well if something happens to me and john
we want you to take care of him i said
we got to feed him
because john moss could eat as a kid and
i said guys
feed him every day they said yes
and then spike him when he acts up
well i agree to that
but john miles do you mind just stand up
john miles stand up
that's john miles now
no now wait a minute
take a good look at john miles i'm four
feet eleven
and almost they tell me almost 90 years
old
and there he is and i was supposed to
spank him
when he doesn't do right
now when i walk up to john miles to give
him a spanking i got to get permission
from him can i spank you because he's
pretty big now
but i love john miles then
and i love john miles now and i will
take care of you and spank you
whether you like it or not okay
but lillian and john
stayed married i put it together
but it lasted 43 years that's not a bad
record is it
they were happy and lolan gave him
every support a wife could ever give
a partner and they gave love
to john miles in the process
john was an unusual individual
ambassador young is sitting over here
and we all loved him all the time
his sincerity was apparent
he worked hard and he said
that he wasn't going to stop
and i don't need to tell you anything
about john all of you knew him
all of you know his fervor
and his commitment to equity and the
love he had for
everybody
and i want us
to look at the john we
thought we knew the john who convinced
us we knew
the real man because he was constant
but i asked him one time john what in
the world
is bad trouble i said when
i was a young girl my sister now we were
courting every time we go out on a date
my mother said okay have a good time but
don't get in no trouble
well we didn't know nothing else except
trouble was not good
but john said the good trouble
is when your mother says
don't get in trouble find a way
to right the wrongs of our society
and he did a pretty decent job of that
and during this week
john was on television all day every day
and i love young people and i had an
opportunity when people know that i like
young people so i was invited to speak
to
a group of kids and i said to them as
you're watching television i want you to
know that's not
a public relations program you're
watching
that's a story of a man who lived the
life they're talking about
john made a decision on the kind of life
he was going to live
and i said to those young people that
you have the responsibility of making
your life
have the meaning you want it to be
you can either decide to be the bank
robber
or the bank owner it's your choice
the man you sing on television decided
that his life was going to have a
quality
to it do as much as you can
as long as you can as often as you can
because that's what john lewis did
we won't forget john but i
would want to tell you don't sit here
and listen to these phrases don't forget
what you read in the newspapers how
wonderful he was
do something about the man he asked us
to be in ourselves and that is
be kind to everybody love everybody
speak up and speak out i don't need to
tell you that you know what he said
but what you can do and i want to advise
you
and admonish you to really give meaning
to the john we love
vote thank you
bronson
to john miles
and obama speaker pelosi
madam mayor romans
8 18 tells us for i consider the
sufferings of the present time
to not be worthy of the glory which
shall be revealed to us
when i met john lewis over 40 years ago
our lives
intersected because in 1960 he came to
my hometown raleigh north carolina
to form snick at a small black college
shaw university where my father
who is president of the naacp led
nightly civil rights demonstrations
again in 1963 our lives intersected
because my father returned from the
march on washington
he began raving about a speaker
young john lewis who had electrified the
crowd
and so imagine when i finally met him in
atlanta in 1976
as a young law student it was a
transcendent moment
like meeting a historical figure thomas
jefferson or
benjamin franklin who wrote the
declaration of independence but yet here
was someone who had made
america live up to those noble words
along with dr king and reverend
abernathy and
andy young and
joseph lowery and ct vivian another
lion who we lost on the same day as john
lewis
john had an incorruptible integrity
and an ideological purity which was like
a halo
somehow this extended to everyone who
was in his orbit
myself included and that's the reason
the nation has paused from pandemic
and protests and politics
to bid him farewell today
virtually every news organization has
hailed john as a civil rights hero
but john was a women's rights hero
a gay rights hero a senior rights hero
a worker's hero an immigrant rights hero
john wasn't on the right side of history
history was on the right side
of john lewis
and in his spare time he introduced the
legislation to create the
african-american history museum
and he fought the bigots in congress for
15 years
until he triumphed yet again against
insurmountable odds
one of his proudest moments was standing
at the dedication
of that monumental structure four years
ago
and for those who wondered if perhaps
his time had passed
with his body ravaged with cancer so
frail
and fragile that he yielded to a cane
and what he surely knew would be his
last public appearance
he summoned the strength and to walk to
the middle of black
lives plaza in washington d.c
to express his solidarity and support
for the young protesters who have begun
to change america as
john lewis did as a young man
they say that the victors write history
and so i declare today that the history
of the 20th century as it is written
john lewis will stand beside gandhi and
king
and mandela as one of the great
transformative freedom fighters of
humankind
and while the nation mourns a great
leader i will miss
a dear loving and loyal friend who
allowed me the extraordinary privilege
to walk
along beside a living saint
st louis
in the last days of his life
when we both knew that death was
imminent
i desperately wanted to tell john about
how much he had meant to me into the
country
but in a solemn moment he pulled me
closer and he whispered
everyone has to vote in november
it is the most important election ever
and i promised him that with every fiber
in my body i would tell everyone if you
truly want to honor this humble hero
make sure that you vote first
corinthians tells us when faith
hope and love remain the greatest of
these is love
john lewis was love
good night sweet prince
make flights of angels carry thee to
that rest
thank you
so
good afternoon
i have on two masks because i have mr
lewis's voice in my head and you could
say be particular
my name is jamila thompson
and on behalf of the staff
i would like to thank john miles
and the entire lewis family
for the honor and the privilege of
sharing the congressman
and mrs lewis who was his partner
in life and in public service
with generations of the staff for the
last 33 years
in the celebration of his life and his
legacy
the congressman would want me to tell
you as i look at you today and you're
his favorite color that you look good
you look fresh you look clean you look
beautiful
thank you we are honored to serve you
and we were honored to serve him
we would also like to express our
sincere and our great appreciation
to the speaker of the house of
representatives
the majority leader the majority whip
the clerk of the house of
representatives
the office of employee assistance the
congressional black caucus
and all of your amazing staff for your
patience
and your guidance during this very
difficult time
people always ask us what was it like to
work for congressman lewis
what was he like up close what was he
like in real life
and it is too difficult to explain
so our answer was always the same
he's just as you may imagine but better
and that no day was ever the same
what do you know about the congressman
is true he was a gentleman
he was truly of the people and a
peaceful soul
when he came into the office every
single day he would greet every staffer
every fellow every intern
with a good morning sir a good morning
ma'am
he would end every request every
successful speech
every successful bill every hearing
every markup with
thank you thank you young brother thank
you sister thank you my child
or my dear as staff we felt it was our
duty to create
and maintain a space where the
congressman could be completely and holy
himself
in college we often say that there's the
freshman 15 that you gain a little bit
around
well in our office there was the john
lewis 20.
because he and michael would bring in
lunch and far far too often dessert
because some cake or some pie or some
brownie
would be calling out to them in the
grocery store and they would want
everyone to come together
and sit down and share a meal
we were a little family a little enclave
a lot of drama a lot of fun
and so much love
he broke down those work barriers and he
welcomed
our parents our spouses our children our
grandchildren our nieces and nephews our
god children and our friends
into the circle making them fall equally
in awe
of his greatness sometimes the world got
a little glimpse of our nest
during these impromptu gatherings and
certain videos may go viral
while we were like a well-loyal machine
when it came to policy
and casework
although we were like that public
he enjoyed stirring things up in the
office
you might call him a little bit of an
instigator
he would get us in trouble with michael
try and corner us with questions and
stir things up and with time you knew
not to take the bait
and you would learn and to say oh no
congressman you're not gonna get me
today
and he would laugh i think that that's
what i'm gonna miss the most
i'm gonna miss his laugh and not the one
that you see on television
you know but the one where he would be
sitting back and shooting the wind
and he would throw back his head and he
would just laugh from his heart
from his belly from his soul
so many workers are often taught to be
invisible
but with mr lewis he always saw you and
made you feel
special and worthy dr king and rosa
parks spent time with him as a teenager
and it changed the
course of his life so i believe that he
spent
every waking moment paying it forward
he could be absolutely exhausted but
still take one more picture
spend one more moment especially with
young people
this meant that we were always always
always behind schedule
so the very first lesson in staffing the
congressman
was to learn to operate on john lewis
time
which translates into late but trusting
that it would always work out
as he told everyone he could out walk
the entire staff and so our duty was to
keep up
when it was time to move we did but when
it was time to be present
and the congressman needed a little bit
of quiet
we would try to create that space
he would slow down to appreciate and
absorb the majesty of the moment for his
own mental archives
just as we tried to preserve the
sanctity of his space
he allowed us to be our true and
authentic selves
just the very best version he found
staff who were unique
and i think represented either a little
bit of his personality
or what he needed to compliment it we
made our ways
to mr lewis through very random paths
coincidences some strategies or others
and for believers through divine
intervention
he didn't hire based on a resume but
your any
energy your being your essence your
passion and your potential
we were a medley group of musicians air
traffic controllers photographers
dancers social workers entertainers
entertainers
artists historians and every once in a
while an actual lawyer
or a political scientist
he got all into our business
and was there in spirit or in person
for the big moments
in the same way that he always took a
call from mrs lewis or john miles
he let us drop everything in a family
emergency
and generations of children have fond
memories of hanging out in his office
as their parents worked nearby he let us
be our spell
ourselves especially when it came
to civic participation he let us
organize
protest testify and always always
always vote
we try to absorb his energy and his
lessons
to my knowledge three staff
served him for over 20 years
ruth berg terry butler
and first first cousin michael collins
may you please stand
and there's a whole generation of staff
who are right behind them
at 19 at 15 at 17 at 12 at 10 years at
14 years
ruth riley brenda jones jared mckinley
rachelle o'neal
and then there are the staffers who
could never really leave
like linda chastain and jacob gillison
whom he kept pulling back
in as friends and confidants
although some of you and some people
moved on
you couldn't really because his spirit
was in you forever
his voice is always in our head be kind
be mindful be particular
make it plain make it simple make it
sing
working for him was a little bit of a
nightmare sometimes
because as no matter how hard we worked
he always worked harder
every single day he woke up at the crack
of dawn
watched the news and read the newspapers
his memory was like a living
encyclopedia
which means he forgot nothing and could
pull something back from 10 years ago
because he knew it was the same staff
and we were still there
he expected us to be informed with facts
from primary sources not hearsay
and when he walked into the office he
would ask what constituents were calling
and writing about and add that
information to his endless archives
you learned the hard way or the subtle
way because he was not direct
that when he asked you a question he
usually knew the answer
but wanted to see whether or not you
could represent him
and his constituents when preparing for
a big vote
or a big speech he would drop a subtle
hint
have you read this poem this speech a
book
some scripture do you remember this
painting
and then he would say let's come back
and talk about it later on
this little hint would prepare you for
the aftermath
of those executive sessions that he had
with himself
and after those sessions we would learn
how and in which direction the spirit
moved in
and then we would have our marching
orders
he would take the essence of a
complicated policy
and make it accessible and real to the
people
the congressman loves serving on the
ways and means committee
he always showed up and he hated to miss
votes on the floor let me say that again
he could not stand to miss votes the
voice messages i have from him
about the votes that he was about to
miss are still on my
my phone to this day this is the reason
why we are so
thankful that congressman kildee and his
staff were willing to serve
and to help us cast his ballots during
this pandemic
and to service his proxy
a congressman would walk the halls or
sit in committee or sit in the office
and he loved the beauty of the house of
representatives
he loved its closeness to the people and
the complicated reflection
of the staff of the status of our nation
every visitor to our office received a
full dose
of southern hospitality the offer of a
georgia coach
some peanuts a brief tour of his office
and sometime on our beloved balcony with
its stunning view
of the u.s capitol while he loved
this country and all its people the
record should be clear
on his immense pride in representing
georgia's fifth congressional district
he was so proud to represent metro
atlanta
and all of its cities all of its
counties and all of its people
he was on a mission to serve to make
them feel heard
respected and represented regardless of
where they fell
on the political spectrum the
constituents
were our compass and congressman lewis
worked around the clock
to find solutions to their challenges
when it came to public service and
public policy
his name did not need to be on the
headlines
or on the front lines it was the action
and the results that mattered not every
problem needs a bill
and he could always find compromise
without
compromising his values or his
principles
when the challenge presented itself he
played the long game
and he knew every trick in the book and
he expected the staff
to fight in a non-violent manner for the
people
when constituents were concerned about
the rights of soviet jewry
he took action when faced with
inequality and health services
he advanced technical changes to reduce
the cost and increase
services to life-saving care especially
for
the issues that affected communities of
color like kidney disease
and copd
when workers faced pensions issues you
found ways to give them security
when families were separated by
immigration policies
he worked around the clock to reunite
them when people couldn't get their
social security checks
he fought and sometimes for years to
make that happen when taxpayers
were struck and workers struggled with
an outdated bureaucracy of the irs
he worked to modernize the entire agency
when he heard from frustrated veterans
he fought
for their respect their earned benefits
and their care
when he saw an alarming increase in
abusive relationships
he developed strategies to stop the
cycle before it began
when some tried to eliminate the us
institute of peace he found a way and
built a coalition to keep that building
and the prospect and the hope of peace
still alive
when he was worried about the state of
our globe for generations yet unborn
he introduced the environmental justice
act
when looking at the rights of
marginalized communities around the
world he worked to diversify the face of
our diplomacy
and insert empathy and standards to our
global policies
and when people complained about
immovable lines to vote
he co-wrote the voter empowerment act
the list is too long to recognize
his legislative and policy successes and
the impact
that he has on people across the nation
and around the world
so i ask you as we sit in this historic
space
and as you drive through metro atlanta
and you feel when you see the greatness
of his legacy
historic preservation and civic
education
i ask that you hold that in your heart
and your soul and your spirit
he felt that we needed to know and study
our history
to make sure that we never repeated it
he was both human and divine
it is so difficult to explain the
magnitude the genius
the gentle grace of this man
i would ask at this moment for the staff
to take a stand
please so that you can see and know just
a sample of who we are
former staff
thank you
a few years ago we had a reunion and we
realized that there aren't that many
staff
we have a lot of interns and a lot of
fellows but the congressman held us
close
i don't think that there are many
offices where you have the opportunity
to hold your boss's hand into a justice
tie and to tell
every person that you love them
he created the space he created this
family
as a staff we are heartbroken we are
lost
but we know that the work continues the
fight remains
and we cannot we must not get lost in
the sea of despair
so if asked how you may honor the
congressman
i will echo the words of the greats who
stood here before
you can make sure that his work his
sacrifice's message
lives on and that there are actions that
every person can do regardless of their
age
or their station in life be kind
be mindful recognize the dignity
and the worth of every human being
be the best version of yourself
be informed stay engaged even though the
work is hard
and if you are age of age and eligible
for the love of god please vote thank
you
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone my name is
sheila o'brien and i
am the sixth niece congressman
john lewis to each distinguished
guest member of clergy family and
friends
on behalf of the lewis family we would
like to say thank you
from the very depths of our hearts for
the outpour of love
support words of encouragement and
prayer
the honor the respect
the camaraderie that has been bestowed
upon the lewis family will never be
forgotten
we would also like to take this
opportunity to give a heartfelt thanks
to the chief of staff
michael collins who has now become first
cousin
and to each staff member
and to each staff member that has worked
tirelessly with
and for congressman lewis especially
during this time
words are not enough to express how
grateful we are for all
that you have done especially for our
cousin john miles
i am here today to pay tribute to a man
that was larger than life to the world
he is known as the honorable congressman
john lewis but to his siblings he's
affectionately known as robert
and to his many nieces and nephews he is
known
as uncle robert so if you would permit
me to just call him
uncle robert right now i'd be grateful
uncle robert loved his family and we as
you can tell loved him
he was a son to our grandparents eddie
lewis
who we called granddaddy buddy and
willie may louis who we call
mo he was the husband to one wife
our unlillian the father to one son
our cousin john miles and the brother to
a lot of siblings too many to name right
now we don't have time
while we knew how important he and his
work
was to the world when we were with him
we saw uncle robert we saw the man
that enjoyed spending time with this
family
reminiscing about days gone by catching
up on family dynamics
enjoying a good meal sharing laughter
and love
we like the world knew the john
robert lewis that personified hope
courage bravery and sheer
humanitarianism
as we all know before he was chosen to
congress
yes i say chosen because the word of god
tells me that
many are called but few are chosen
his first call was to that of the civil
rights movement
for the last 60 years as a non-violent
civil rights
activist he was a voice for those that
couldn't speak
defeat for those that couldn't walk and
the champion of injustice for those that
couldn't fight
he along with many other civil rights
icons became
the change agents that the world so
desperately needed
as a member of congress he was known as
the conscience of congress
for over 30 years he stood in solidarity
with the 5th congressional district of
georgia
he has been recognized revered and held
to the highest esteem
for the work he's done to build a better
community
he broke barriers he tore down walls he
defied
stereotypes and refused to be moved from
his stance on injustice
liberty and freedom he made time for
everyone and was always picture ready
he did not miss an opportunity for a
photo op or to just take a few moments
to talk to his content
constituents or to those that revered
him
his love was contagious and it could be
felt each time you were in his presence
over the last several days listening to
the numerous accompli
accomplishments some of which he labored
for years
over it is evident why his life
is being celebrated at this magnitude
he truly made an impact not just on
america but on the world so today we
celebrate the life of congressman
john lewis our uncle robert the man who
labored
the men who talked the men who walked
fought knelt sat
held hands with both blacks and whites
bled
lifted his voice bent his knees
and was willing to give up his life for
a righteous cause
let's continue this celebration of life
by taking another baton that he has now
laid down
and endeavor to get into trouble good
trouble necessary trouble
let's not give up let's not give in
let's never give out let's keep the
faith
keep our eyes on the prize rest in power
uncle robert may your legacy live on and
never die
we believe you have heard the words from
our heavenly father
well done thou good and faithful servant
well done and i say to all of us
weeping may endure for a night
but joy comes in the morning guess what
it's morning time
[Music]
a few years ago congressman john lewis
attended the inauguration of an american
president
and although he had seen many presidents
he
made a beeline to this president
and asked him to sign his program
he signed the program in this way
because of you john
it's my esteemed honor to welcome back
to the ebenezer pulpit 44th president of
the united states of america
barack obama but before he comes
jennifer holliday will come once again
take my hand precious lord
lead me on
[Music]
praise
[Music]
i am tired
i am weak
i am
through
storms
[Music]
lead me on
[Music]
to
[Music]
take my hand
[Music]
praise
[Music]
me
when my way
[Music]
grows through
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
precious
and lead me
when the darkness
appears
[Music]
and the night
[Music]
draws near
and the day
[Music]
has passed
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god please
take my hand
take my hand
pray just
[Music]
[Applause]
right now we need to right now
we got a world that's in sorrow we don't
know what's gonna happen tomorrow
[Music]
we don't know which way to go
[Music]
[Music]
hey
take my hand
[Music]
pray just
[Music]
right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
james wrote to the believers
consider it pure joy
my brothers and sisters
whenever you face trials of many kinds
because you know that
the testing of your faith produces
perseverance
let perseverance finish its work
so that you may be mature and complete
lacking nothing
it is a great honor
[Music]
to be back in
ebenezer baptist church
in the pulpit of its greatest pastor
dr martin luther king jr
to pay my respects to perhaps his finest
disciple
an american whose faith was tested
again and again to produce
a man of pure joy
and unbreakable perseverance
john robert lewis
to those who have spoken to
presidents bush and clinton madam
speaker reverend warnock
robin king john's family friends his
beloved staff
mayor bottoms
i've come here today because i like so
many americans
owe a great debt to john lewis
and his forceful vision
of freedom
now this country is a constant work in
progress
we're born with instructions
to form a more perfect union
explicit in those words is the idea that
we're imperfect
that what gives each new generation
purpose
is to take up the unfinished work of the
last and
carry it further than any might have
thought possible
john lewis first of the freedom riders
head of the student nonviolent
coordinating committee youngest speaker
at the march on washington leader
of the march from selma to montgomery
member of congress representing the
people of this state
and this district for 33 years mentor
to young people
including me at the time
until his final day on this earth
he not only embraced that responsibility
but he made it his life's work
which isn't bad for a boy from troy
john was born into modest means that
means he was pole
in the heart of the jim crow south
to parents who picked somebody else's
cotton
apparently he didn't take to farm work
on days when he was supposed to help his
brothers and sisters with their labor
he'd hide under the porch and make a
break for the school bus
when it showed up
his mother willie may louis nurture that
curiosity
in this shy serious child
once you learn something she told her
son once you get
something inside your head no one can
take it away from you
as a boy john listened through the door
after bedtime
as his father's friends complained about
the clan
one sunday as a teenager he heard dr
king preach
on the radio
as a college student in tennessee he
signed up
for jim lawson's workshops on the tactic
of non-violent civil disobedience
john lewis was getting something inside
his head
an idea he couldn't shake took hold on
that nonviolent resistance and civil
disobedience
were the means to change laws but also
change hearts and change minds
and change nations
and change the world
so he helped organize the nashville
campaign in 1960.
he and other young men and women sat at
a segregated lunch count
well-dressed straight back refusing to
let
a milkshake poured on their heads or a
cigarette extinguished
on their backs or a foot
aimed at their ribs
refused to let that dent their dignity
and their sense of purpose
and after a few months the nashville
campaign achieved the first
successful desegregation of public
facilities in any
major city in the south
john got a taste of jail
for the first second third
well several times
but he also got a taste of victory
and it consumed him with righteous
purpose
and he took the battle deeper into the
side
that same year just weeks after the
supreme court ruled
that segregation of interstate bus
facilities was unconstitutional
john and bernard lafayette
bought two tickets climbed aboard a
greyhound
sat up front and refused to move
this was months before the first
official freedom riots
he was doing a a test
trip was unsanctioned few knew what
they were up to
and at every stop through the night
apparently
the angry driver stormed out of the bus
and into the bus station
and john and bernard had no idea what he
might come back with
or who he might come back with
nobody was there to protect them
there were no camera crews to record
events
we you know sometimes rev
we we read about this and we kind of
take it for granted or at least we
we we act as if
it was inevitable imagine the courage
of two people malia's age
younger than my oldest daughter
on their own
to challenge an entire infrastructure of
oppression
john was only 20 years old
but he pushed all 20 of those years to
the center of the table
betting everything all of it
that his example could challenge
centuries of convention and generations
of brutal violence and countless
daily indignities suffered by
african-americans
like john the baptist preparing the way
like those old testament prophets
speaking truth to kings
john lewis did not hesitate and he kept
on
getting on board buses and sitting at
lunch counters
got his mug shot taken again and again
marched
again and again on a mission
to change america
spoke to a quarter million people at the
march on washington
when he was just 23.
helped organize the freedom summer in
mississippi when he was just
24.
at the ripe old age of 25
john was asked to lead the march from
selma to montgomery
he was warned that governor wallace had
ordered
troopers to use violence but he and
jose williams and others
led them across that bridge anyway
and we've all seen the film and the
footage and the photographs
president clinton mentioned the trench
coat
knapsack
the book to read the apple to eat the
toothbrush
apparently jails
weren't big on such creature comforts
and you look at those pictures
[Music]
and and john looks so young and he's
small
in stature
look in every bit that shy serious child
that his mother had raised and yet
he's full of purpose
god's put perseverance in it
and we know what happened to the
marchers that day
their bones were cracked by billy clubs
their eyes and lungs choked with tear
gas
they knelt a prey which made their heads
easier targets
and john was struck in the skull and he
thought he was going to die
surrounded by the sight of young
americans gagging and bleeding
and trampling
victims in their own country
of state-sponsored violence
and the thing is i imagine
initially that day
the troopers thought they'd won the
battle
you can imagine the conversations they
had afterwards
you can imagine them saying yeah we
showed them
they figured they turned the protesters
back over the bridge
that they'd kept that they preserved
a system that denied the basic humanity
of their fellow citizens
except this time there were some cameras
there
this time the world saw what happened
bore witness to black americans
who were
asking for nothing more than to be
treated
like other americans
who were not asking for special
treatment just equal treatment
promised to them a century before
and almost another century before that
and when john woke up
and checked himself out of the hospital
he would make sure the movement that was
in the words of scripture hard-pressed
on every side but not crushed
perplexed but not in despair
persecuted but not abandoned
struck down
but not destroyed
so he returned to brown chapel
a battered prophet bandages around his
head
and he said more marchers will come now
and the people came
and the troopers parted
and the marches reached montgomery
and their words reached the white house
and lyndon johnson son of the south
said we shall overcome
and the voting rights act
was signed into law
the life of john lewis was in so many
ways
exceptional
it vindicated the faith
in our founding redeemed that faith
that most american of ideas the idea
that
any of us ordinary people without rank
or will or title or fame
can somehow point out the imperfections
of this nation and come together and
challenge the status quo
and decide that it is in our power to
remake this country
that we love until it more closely
aligns
with our highest ideals
what a radical what a revolutionary
notion this idea that any of us ordinary
people
a young kid from troy
can stand up to the powers and
principalities and say no
this isn't right this isn't true this
isn't just
we can do better
on the battlefield of justice
americans like john americans like
reverence lowry and ct
vivian two other patriots that we lost
this year
liberated all of us
americans
came to take for granted
america was built by people like them
america was built by john lewis's
[Applause]
he as much as anyone in our history
brought this country a little bit closer
to our highest ideals
and someday when we do finish that long
journey towards freedom
when we do form a more perfect union
whether it's years from now or decades
or
even if it takes centuries john lewis
will be a founding father of that fuller
fairer better america
and yet as exceptional as john was
here's the thing john never believed
that what he did was more than any
citizen of this country can do
i i mentioned in the statement
the day john passed
the thing about john was just how gentle
and humble he was
and despite this storied remarkable
career
he treated everyone
with kindness and respect
because it was
innate to him this idea that
any of us can do what he did
if we're willing to persevere
he believed that in all of us there
exists
the capacity for great courage
all of us there's a longing to do what's
right
that in all of us there's a willingness
to love all people
and extend to them their god-given
rights
to dignity and respect
so many of us lose that sense
it's taught out of us
we we start feeling as if
in fact we can't afford to extend
kindness or
decency to other people
that we're better off
if we're above other people and looking
down on it
and so often that's encouraged
john always said he always saw the best
in us
and he never gave up and never stopped
speaking out
because he saw the best in us he
believed in us
even when we didn't believe in ourselves
and as a congressman he didn't rest he
kept getting himself arrested
as an old man he didn't sit out
any fight sat in all night long
on the floor of the united states
capitol
i know his staff was stressed
but the testing of his faith produced
perseverance
he knew that the march is
not over that the race is not yet won
that we have not yet reached that
blessed destination
where we are judged by the content of
our character
he knew from his own life that progress
is fragile
that we have to be vigilant against
the dark occurrence of this country's
history
of our own history with their whirlpools
of violence
and hatred and despair that can always
rise again
bull connor may be gone
but today we witness with our own eyes
police officers kneeling on the necks
of black americans
george wallace may be gone
but we can witness
our federal government sending agents to
use tear gas and batons
against peaceful demonstrators
we may no longer have to guess the
number of jelly beans in a jar
in order to cast a ballot
but we sit here
there are those in power who are doing
their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
even undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
now i know this is a celebration of
john's life
there are some who might say
[Music]
we shouldn't dwell on such things
but that's why i'm talking about it
john lewis devoted his time on this
earth
the very attacks on democracy
and what's best in america that
we're seeing circulate right now
he knew that every single one of us
has a god-given power and that the fate
of this democracy depends on how we use
it
that democracy isn't automatic
it has to be nurtured
it has to be tended to we have to work
at it it's hard
and so he knew that it depends on
whether we summon
a measure just to measure john's moral
courage to question
what's right and what's wrong and call
things
as they are he said that as long as he
had a breath in his body
he did everything he could to preserve
this democracy
and as long as we have breath in our
bodies
we have to continue his cause if we want
our children
to grow up in a democracy
not just with elections but
a true democracy
a representative democracy
in a big hearted tolerant vibrant
inclusive america of perpetual
self-creation then
we're going to have to be more like john
we don't have to do all the things he
had to do because he did him for us
but we got to do something
as the lord instructed paul do not be
afraid
go on speaking do not be silent
for i am with you and no one will attack
you to harm you for i have many
in this city my people
it's just everybody's got to
come out and vote we got we got all
those
people in the city but they can't
do nothing like john we've got to
keep getting into that good trouble
he knew that nonviolent protest is
patriotic
a way to raise public awareness and put
a spotlight on injustice
and make the powers that be
uncomfortable
like john we don't have to choose
between protests and politics it's not
an either or a situation
it's a both and situation
we have to engage in protests where
that's effective but
we also have to translate
our passion and our causes
into laws instant
institutional practices that's why john
ran for congress
34 years ago
like john we've got to fight even harder
for the most powerful tool that we have
which is the right to vote
the voting rights act is one of the
crowning achievements
of our democracy it's why john crossed
that bridge
it's why he spilled his blood and by the
way it was the result
of democratic and republican efforts
who spoke here earlier and his father
signed its renewal when they were in
office
[Applause]
president clinton didn't have to because
it was the law when he arrived
so people to register to vote
but once the supreme court weakened
the voting rights act
some state legislators unleashed a flood
of laws
designed specifically to make voting
harder
especially by the way state legislators
where
there's a lot of minority turnout and
population growth
that's not necessarily a mystery or an
accident
it was an attack on what john fought for
it was an attack on our democratic
freedoms
and we should treat it as such
if politicians want to honor john
and i'm so grateful for
the legacy and work of all
the congressional leaders who are here
but there's a better way than a
statement calling him a hero
you want to honor john let's honor him
by revitalizing the law that he was
willing to die for
and by the way
naming it the john lewis voting rights
act
that is a fine tribute
but john wouldn't want us to stop there
just trying to get back to where we
already were
once we pass the john lewis voting
rights act
we should keep marching to make it even
better
by making sure every american is
automatically registered to vote
including former inmates who've earned
their second chance
by adding polling places and expanding
early voting
and making election day a national
holiday so
if you are somebody who's working in a
factory
or you're a single mom who's got to go
to her job
and doesn't get time off
[Applause]
you can still cast your ballot
by guaranteeing that every american
citizen has equal representation
in our government including the american
citizens who live in washington d.c
and in puerto rico they're americans
by ending some of the partisan
gerrymandering
so that all voters have the power to
choose their politicians not the other
way around
and if all this takes eliminating the
filibuster
another jim crow relic in order to
secure the god-given rights of every
american
then that's what we should do
now
even if we do all this even if every
bogus voter suppression law is struck
off the books today
we've got to be honest with ourselves
that too many of us
choose not to exercise the franchise
too many of our citizens believe their
vote
won't make a difference or they buy into
the cynicism
that by the way is the central strategy
of voter suppression
to stop believing in your own power
so we're also going to have to remember
what john said if you don't do
everything
you can do to change things
then they will remain the same
you only pass this way once you have to
give it
all you have as long as young people are
protesting in the streets
hoping real change takes hold
i'm hopeful but we can't casually
abandon them
at the ballot box not when few
elections have been as urgent on so many
levels as this one
we can't treat voting as an errand to
run if we have some time
we have to treat it as the most
important
action we can take on behalf of
democracy
like john we have to give it all we have
i was proud that john lewis was a friend
of mine
he came to speak
and i went up and i said
mr lewis you are one of my heroes
what inspired me more than anything as a
young man was to see
what you and earn lawson
bob moses diane nash
others did
and he got that kind of aw shucks
thank you very much
next time i saw him i'd
been elected to the united states senate
and i told him john you i'm here because
of you
and on inauguration day in 2008
2008
he was one of the first people i greeted
and hugged
on that stand
and i told him this is your day too
he was a good and kind and gentle man
and he believed in us
even when we don't believe in ourselves
and it's fitting that the last time john
and i shared a public forum
was on zoom whether he nor i
set up the zoom call because we didn't
know how to work it
there's a virtual town hall with a
gathering of young activists
who had been helping to lead this
summer's demonstrations in the wake of
george floyd's george floyd's death
and afterwards i spoke to john privately
and he could not have been prouder
to see this new generation of activists
standing up for freedom and equality
a new generation that was intent on
voting and protecting the right to vote
in some cases a new generation running
for political office
and i i told him all those young people
john
of every race and every religion from
every background and gender
and sexual orientation john those are
your children
they learned from your example
even if they didn't always know it
they had understood through him what
american citizenship
requires even if they'd only heard about
his courage
through the history books
by the thousands faceless anonymous
relentless young people black and white
have taken our whole nation back to
those
great wells of democracy which were dug
deep by the founding fathers in the
formulation of the constitution
and the declaration of independence
dr king said that in the 1960s
and it came true again this summer
we see it outside our windows in big
cities
and rural towns in men
and women young and old
straight americans and lgbtq americans
blacks who long for equal treatment and
whites who can no longer accept freedom
for themselves while
witnessing the suffocation of their
fellow americans
[Applause]
we see it in everybody doing the hard
work of overcoming
complacency of overcoming our own fears
and our own prejudices our own
hatreds you see it
in in people trying to be better
truer versions of ourselves
and that's what john lewis teaches us
that's where real courage comes from
not from turning on each other
but by turning towards one another
not by sowing hatred and division
but by spreading love
and truth not by
avoiding our responsibility
embracing those responsibilities with
joy
and perseverance and discovering that
in our beloved community
we do not walk alone
what a gift john lewis was
we are all so lucky to have had him
walk with us for a while
and show us the way
god bless you all god bless america
god bless this gentle soul who pulled it
closer to its promise
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much we are honored to be
here i would like to
thank brother michael collins
uh congressman
pam
so bibi and i and our sister cece we had
opportunity to sing
to him and one of the songs we sang
songs differently but the one song i'd
like for everyone that
would would just join him with we might
[Music]
say
[Music]
someday
oh deep
in my heart
[Music]
on hearing that i heard that he opened
his eyes
because that was the song
to the memory of
uncle robert as she called him
because he treated us all like family
and i hope you enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
yes he knew there was much more
so he asked the lord to show
as he did all he all he
achieved in his life
[Music]
he was willing to fight in the struggle
and he was willing to get a good
was trumpet to get into trouble
he took on the wrong of this world
like civil and voting rights
[Music]
no matter the problems he faced
he kept his eyes on the prize
[Music]
is he
was there when you call don't you worry
he tell the truth in a hurry to fight
for the struggle
[Music]
[Music]
we will continue the fight and be
sure
[Music]
don't you worry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
we should be ready to fight
[Music]
[Applause]
let us pray
and when he shall die
take him and cut him into stars
he shall make the face of heaven so fine
that all the world will grow in love
with night
and pay no worship to the gary's
garrison
gracious and loving god we commend
into your safety
the soul of your son
john robert lewis
you've seen the affidavit of his deeds
yes
he stayed in trouble
good trouble
necessary trouble
he fought the good fight
he finished his course
he kept the faith
and now henceforth is laid up for him a
crown of righteousness
but not only to him but to all those who
love god's appearing
now part of a great mighty cloud of
witnesses
is he these are they who have gone
through the great tribulation
they've washed their robes
in the blood of the lamb
the angels rejoice
because he has been vindicated by
history
his deeds etched into eternity
and his soul received into your glory
in the name of the god who loves us into
freedom
and frees us into loving
through jesus christ our lord we pray
amen
we pray that today was a memorable
worship experience for all of you
now pastor warnock will greet the family
along with reverend dr bernice king
and then we will follow the department
of defense's instructions
as they carry out our representative
lewis
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
y'all stand
[Music]
the family may remain seated thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all right
you
at this time as we prepare to depart
we ask that the members of congress the
extended family
and special invited guests join with us
as we of our honorable
john robert lewis dancing to his
favorite song
by pharrell williams entire happy
this is an opportunity for all of us to
enjoy this worship experience
and to join in and dance with him
and clap along if you feel
[Music]
is
[Music]